well hello everyone and welcome to this
GDL on Hobbit a journey through
middle-earth now I actually have the
team with me from North Kingdom in
Sweden who built the chrome experiment
so I'll hand you over to those guys and
they can introduce themselves yeah hi
I'm Bonnie lyrics on technical director
on the project and this is my friend
Emma yeah I guess thank you for for
joining us so I guess the first thing I
wanted to ask is for anybody who's not
actually been to the site or seen it yet
what kind of things should they actually
expect like what guys what have you guys
put into that experience well we wanted
to create the very visual multimedial
exploration of the characters location
and everything from from the first two
Hobbit movies and we're doing some small
games using WebGL and CSS and some
dramatizations of different scenes the
locations that sounds awesome
so what what kind of technologies or
libraries or frameworks can did you have
to use to bring this whole thing
together yeah for the experiences we
have we have both WebGL based ones that
using three yes and we have a couple of
locations as well that using CSS only so
it can be experienced on other browsers
and Chrome and Firefox on mobile so we
could reach more people with the actual
experiences as well so is is a is a lot
of the code specific to your own engine
I mean you mentioned three J's there did
you did you have to craft a lot of the
engine for yourselves and now actually
we use
much 3gs after this which is pretty
awesome already and I'm way for the for
example in lake time we had physics and
then we used the few years library and
the branch with a camel
then we went from that one okay awesome
okay cool um so obviously with something
like this you've got a lot of moving
parts like you said there's CSS 3d
transforms there's WebGL there's audio
there's imagery just a name like a few
of these things what was the actual
workflow for building the whole
experience because as I say it's real
it's a complex beast and it has to run
well so how did you actually kind of
build up to what we had what we actually
get to see well I think it it all it's
made up of different parts as you say
and coming from from really a more
creative side of it we usually do a lot
of animatics in after-effects
pre-rendering 3d work 3d flows into each
section how we wanted to feel and look
then from that I think it's very much
going into early prototyping because
when you sit there in the room and
trying to discuss a game or project is
without having an actual prototype to
play around with it's very hard for lots
of people to get a common understanding
what you're talking about
yeah but that's and so did you find that
you were you were making a lot of
prototypes and iterating a lot or did
you find that you you just made one or
two prototypes and and that was good
enough I mean how how difficult was it
to arrive at something that you felt was
creatively solid I think for some of the
locations we have done way too many
prototypes and but it but of course it's
it's a very difficult experience to to
create stories around and to to get
something creatively that works
to make something as a tech demo of I
mean it's easy to make something that's
a good story but maybe it doesn't suit
it for a good tech demo and only had at
hand we're making yeah you know it's
been a challenge to create stories that
works or no yeah I mean for anybody
who's not seen it I mean it is a
phenomenal piece of technology that
you've actually manage their craft
you know the WebGL stuff the CSS 3d
stuff and so on but actually it's
actually a very interesting and fun sort
of experience from the story side to
actually go through these parts of the
story and they're sort of their bits
where you scrub through the video back
and forth and read about the characters
and the locations and so on if you want
a sidestep
into a bit of a discussion over WebGL a
technology that I have a lot of love for
but debugging WebGL particularly is
notoriously horrible and difficult
because sometimes all you get is this
black screen and no errors no warnings
just the miserable black screen of
nothingness so I'm curious kind of what
was your what was your sort of your tool
chain
what did debugging look like for you in
terms of finding fixing and squashing
bugs yeah as opposite to you that makes
your own WL engines sometimes we since
we're using the three years mashallah is
taken care of and with a bit of
experience it's it's quite a straight
forward work I think to set up in
initial scenes at least and and avoiding
the black screen often in stages when
starting to implement the 3d stuff but
once you have pointed your camera in the
right direction set up all the lights
and and all the basic stuff it's pretty
straightforward
but then when moving into you like
debugging I mostly use
the vaginal inspector and a Chrome
extension if I want to see for example
what what's getting inside the textures
and especially if this dynamic textures
and post effects and stuff like that you
need to look at but otherwise the
console log is the console output is
also pretty straightforward to see if
there's a shader issues and that's yeah
you've mentioned WebGL inspector if
anybody's not actually used that it's a
it's a Chrome extension by one of the
chrome engineers sorry not chrome
engineers OMAP engineer blue called Ben
Vanek and it basically wraps around all
the WebGL context and gives you a lot of
insight into what's actually going on
there so definitely worth checking out
if you're actually trying to do any work
with with WebGL so I can open a journey
through middle-earth on desktop but I
can also do it on phones and tablets
which is frankly awesome and this is one
of the first times I think I've seen an
experience of this quality available
across platforms so suppose the the
obvious question for me initially is how
did you find the process of building a
genuinely multi device experience yeah
it was a journey it's been a learning
process for us as well as the company
because we haven't been too much into
that before but I mean from beginning it
was a big hurdle to decide what to do
with platforms that didn't support WebGL
for example how to handle that how to
communicate with all different kinds of
mobile devices but couldn't support the
experience from that point I think we
found it pretty similar to normal web
development in terms of actually
building
the website and of course there are like
limitations to it that you have to abide
to well that was actually gonna be my
next question so kind of there are
obvious constraints you know you've got
on the one hand you've got these
desktops with these meaty GPUs on the
other end you've got little handheld
smartphones which you're gonna punish
you if you do the slightest thing wrong
so yeah what what what how did you
actually deal with those constraints you
sort of mentioned that you had to decide
what would go in what would go out you
know just key talk a bit about a bit
more about that process and how you
decided what to include where and and so
on yeah I guess the biggest hurdle was
the memory consumption and because you
you can pretty much hit the roof and
crash the device if you not really
careful with that so loading different
assets for one thing and I'm not only
for for memories for performance as well
because if you smaller a certain scale
it up it's taken less video memory as
well when you surround and so that I
have the GPU as well they've you've sort
of taken a bit of a wander into my next
question I see something I wanted to
talk to you about is the fact that this
thing's running fantastically well
astonishing actually just how well this
thing runs on on mobile devices in
particular where you'd you'd be big
concern I'd definitely be a bit
concerned when you'd sort of talking
WebGL and and and and 3d transforms just
generally that you want to keep this
stuff running fast because otherwise
there's no point thing in including it
it's just going to frustrate the user so
you know what were your performance
considerations and how did you actually
make sure that you're gonna stay at 60
frames a second or as close as you
possibly could to that yeah we we
thought that we didn't really aim at
reaching the 60 frames per second on
mobile
without is much more important that we
keep a stable framerate at a lower frame
rate than then pushing it up to 60 so if
it could be like wrong sorry and that's
enough if you don't have this yank or
the frames keeping going on so I guess
there is much more forgiving if it's not
glitches in there and with that took a
lot of testing yeah we have iterations
to make things move lots of devices
running from quite low end devices yeah
to the newest most performance devices
but then of course we disable stuff on
low-end devices post-effects we reduce
the size of the canvas that is blown -
yeah all the tricks that's needed so
sorry I was gonna say do you then have
to keep a bunch of these devices around
in your studio to just kind of step
through and go okay now how's this
running on on this device and and now
how's this running on this device I mean
that seems like you know a big process
to go through
we were you able to automate or was this
just something that you actually had to
step through and do yourselves every
time you made a release well for once we
had we had a dedicated tester that
actually was responsible for constantly
testing out new versions that we
released but then in development um you
can ask yeah we of course we used
multiple devices during the well
development and and there is so so big
difference between them and for example
the lg Metro super tiny screen up to the
Nexus 10 and also with different GPUs
and screen sizes and I mean the pixel
density and stuff so of course we had
many iterations of testing on the
different devices I guess one of the
biggest are
is the ratio between amount of pixels
like density and screen size on the CPU
and GPU because some devices have way
too many pixels for their own good they
look amazing but they don't they don't
they're not as forgiving I guess when it
comes to performance yeah okay so what
are you looking back over this project
now what would you say you're most proud
of from the whole thing I guess both
from a creative point of view but also a
technical point of view you can yeah go
go crazy whatever you like
yeah I think my I'm most proud of is
that we managed to make the experience
feel very tight like you're an app that
isn't glitchy that is you really went
that extra mile to try to even though we
have to unload each section for bit
between sections and load the next one
so on to keep memory consumption low I
think we managed that by really putting
haha work with doing translation
transitions to from the different
sections trying to keep this audio as
fluent throughout the experience as
possible so I'm very yes you don't feel
like it's a gap and then you have to
load and load and load so we have its of
course many loaders in this site as well
because it's pretty large but since we
we load small chunks and we show a
splash screen and load the rest and it
feels like you can let the user be
immersed instead of just sit around
waiting for it does it does to me I know
North Kingdom has a very rich history in
flash it actually feels a lot more like
the latter stages that we had with with
a lot of the flash work where Studios
were getting very experienced
if you know when to and load and load to
try and keep the user engaged and it
feels like a lot of that stuff is still
very applicable today even though we're
delivering in HTML Javascript CSS WebGL
all those technologies it still feels
like a lot of those techniques are still
valid and still useful and helpful what
do you guys think I mean I mean often
the brief is still the same the brief
from the client and the goal you trying
to achieve and so that's not changing
that's why we always have thought that
to get really immersed into an
experience it has to really have that
love in every pixel and that's so before
you before you started on the whole
project did you have any assumptions
about what how this was going to play
out or what it was gonna be like that
you then during the project you just
thought Matt we were so wrong with that
you know did you have any assumptions
that were basically blown to you know
blown to pieces throughout the the build
and the creative work that you did I
guess one thing is we didn't really
thought that the Coleman would be that
good on the device it's actually so like
early in the project we had a lot of
discussions but we actually could do and
I mean we need to have super simple
version for mobile devices but then
gradually we could add more and more and
more and I'm personally pretty amazed
what you can do with devices these days
right now it takes really long time to
to make it site like this but I think
that in in a very short future we will
take this for granted that we used
mobile in this way and when making sites
like this I think one thing for example
is the 3d models were used in WebGL
experiments from the beginning we really
set the aim on on using much lower all
accounts less complex models but that is
something that we check tracing
for some arts that's a trick that's
worked that is awesome I asked the
question having no idea what you'd
actually answer with and I'm I'm so
happy that your answer is things perform
better than we thought they would but on
the other side if you could change one
thing about the web platform that would
have met perhaps made this whole thing a
bunch easier what would it be what would
you change about building for the web I
think we really discussed hard when we
how do you gonna put this question and
we don't really have a good answer
one thing that usually is the big
blocker and it always comes up in
discussions is like integrated video on
mobile to be able to create interactive
video experiences because that's
something we get in every most every
brief from a client but I don't know I
mean there's a reason to why that's the
case and I'm not sure it's would be a
better world given that way okay I would
say also to have a better workflow with
animations and vector-based graphics
there is so many techniques that you can
use and it's scattered all over the
place but maybe not changing the
platform but the the the workflow for us
developers to get all those techniques
under the same roof and yeah use them
easily okay so something like this is an
experience like a journey through
middle-earth is naturally very cutting
edge in what it's trying to do and the
techniques that you've used were there
any resources that you you relied on or
that you looked at to help you build it
as you were going through or is it just
something that you you just had to
iterate through on your own and just
kind of hope for the best I think that
how how the development community looks
like now is we haven't had had it easier
than its
find us answer in stock because you use
dependencies in components and and
github and Twitter is so so easy to get
access to to not only the ones that
wrote the code from the beginning but
all the communities behind like the
Irish are alone three years all those
people they're helpful can just quickly
answer if you have anything and so yeah
I think it's with this it sounds like
people power is is basically the answer
you know IRC Twitter github go to the to
the people there are loads of really
experienced and helpful developers that
will actually help you kind of get to
your own goal yeah yeah well there are
two articles by you guys on html5 rocks
which I really recommend that steps
through in a bit more detail some of the
the technical challenges that you've
faced and if you've not seen a journey
through middle-earth yet definitely go
and check that out it's well worth the
time to just explore every nook and
cranny
I had one heck of a time trying to get
all the the correct answers to Smaug and
not get burnt to a crisp but that's
definitely worth your time as well it's
plenty fun listening to Benedict
Cumberbatch there's his his dragon thing
but all the same in any case guys thank
you so much for taking some time out and
catch you next time yeah thank you have
another thank you